should we joining us now for labor
Shadow Financial secretary um James
Murray hi it's good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program How
concerned should we be about what
happened at the palace last night
well I think we need to find out exactly
what happened and obviously security is
Paramount particularly around an event
like this where we're going to have a
world leaders from around the globe
coming to London for the coronation the
security is is absolutely you know
Central to what's going on on the way
here to the studio this morning you can
see some of the security
um getting in place and we need to
support the security services to do
their job
heart from the home office
for the home office
and the foreign secretary have all sat
there and all told me that coming over
on boats small boats is illegal but this
is what he said this morning have a
listen
there are legal ways in which those who
have a Justified reason for asylum in
the United Kingdom can take it and they
really should not be empowering people
traffickers or organize crime groups by
using illegal means because it's not
illegal there is a well the organized
crime groups that are operating that's
illegal that is releasing the channel on
a boat is not illegal but it is wrong to
subsidize or support in any way organize
crime groups and I don't think any of us
would support the idea that we should
have organized crime groups profiting
from Human misery and sadly that's what
we're seeing in the channel and that's
what we're seeing in the Mediterranean
technology it's not illegal don't we
we're in a small boat what we
acknowledge is that organized crime
groups are making an absolute Fortune
out of human misery and this is deeply
wrong it's a form of human trafficking
that has brought misery to quite
literally millions you know we see is it
illegal on a small boat across the
channel okay we see we
it's not illegal to be a victim of human
trafficking thank you but it's not
illegal
what is labor think
well I think the one thing which I would
agree with um with Tom and in that clip
just there on um is that the problem
here is with the human traffickers with
the people Smugglers who are pushing
people onto these small boats exploiting
them benefiting from them from the
situation financially
um and in the debate we've been having
in Parliament about small boats and
about Channel Crossings what we've been
saying um is that rather than spending
money on things like the Rwanda scheme
that is unethical and impractical hasn't
worked and so on that money should go
into a cross-border police force to go
after across the channel on that well
you know what the people of Smugglers
are doing should be stopped you know and
that's the important thing across the
channel in a small boat well obviously
people getting on a boat shouldn't be
getting on that whether it's legal or
not well it's a question and it's of
course it's a reasonable question to ask
you I'm asking what Labor's view is is
it illegal to get on a small boat and
cross the channel well like it's it's
what the people I I I'm not going to get
into whether that's legal or not what
because the important here is to stop
people getting all the small boats in
the first place yeah and so is it
illegal to do it well I think I
genuinely think the real Point here is
about what the government's response is
question we want to we want to stop
people getting on those small boats in
the first place well I don't think
people getting on it on a small boat are
in Desperate situations
well I don't know the legalities of
whether people getting on the small
boats uh is illegal or not what we need
to do is stop them getting on those
small boats because people are being
exploited getting on those small boats
people are then dying um in the channel
when they're crossing the channel when
people traffickers people Smugglers are
getting them into the UK that's what we
need to stop and the whole approach that
the government's been taking is to set
up the Rwanda scheme and so on which has
been unworkable unethical a waste of
money and so on we need to put that
money into that cross-border police
force to stop the people smuggled in the
first place we should know if it's
illegal or not to take that action as
far as tuition fees are concerned we
were told that they would be scrapped
now we're being told by your leader that
they won't be scrapped why not
well look you know what's really
important to recognize is that these the
system is broken you know what Kirsten
said very clearly is the system which
for funding higher education you know
doesn't work for students it doesn't
work for universities it doesn't work
for the taxpayer and we need to change
that now what we need to do is come up
with a solution and we will set up our
solution in Good Time ahead of the next
general election solution in the um in
the manifesto and he said that you were
going to scrap tuition fees now he's
saying you're not going to if that
wasn't the manifesto um that that was
some some pledges that clear set out
during his leadership
let me be really clear about this you
know so during the the leadership
campaign for the labor party uh Kia set
out his values he set out what drives
him yet none of that has changed you
know whether that is making the economy
fairer whether it's tackling climate
change or whether it's restoring public
services and so on what has changed in
the last three years is the world you
know the world has changed the last
three years and the Tories have crashed
the economy if we want a government the
next election we would inherit a mess
economically we need to make sure that
anything we set out in our Manifesto
ahead of the next general election is
practical fairly costed fully funded and
deliverable and as a long-term solution
rather than More Steam plaster politics
you're sure it wasn't in the labor
Manifesto
we haven't got a manifest 2019 labor
Manifesto issue it wasn't in there 2019
is history you know we're talking about
what the manifesto would be going into
the next what he says in 2019 doesn't
matter well at every election you know
you set out Manifesto for the upcoming
election you know you do not you are not
tied by the last time you thought that
the tuition fees should be scrapped but
now you don't think it should be
scrapped and I'm just asking you why
should we take any notice of whatever
your leadership there are two really
important points here you know number
one you know no party is constrained by
the last Manifesto when you're going
into the next election you have
Manifesto for that election um but the
other really important Point
um is quite how much the world has
changed in the last three years you know
not least because of what Liz trusts and
quasi quite did last Autumn crash in the
economy the impact of which we're still
feeling and it would be the right thing
for us to do as a responsible party
wanting to get into government uh to set
out plans which are practical
fully costed fully funded and work given
the economic context that we would
inherit if we won the next general
election okay so that's the situation on
tuition fees um also abandoning the tax
rise plan for the top five percent what
else is he going to change his mind on
or you talk about you know taxes and
actually what we've been setting out
throughout the last few years is the
leader making promises that he then goes
back on what cures someone who's called
flip-flop what you know what kissed
armor is set out during his leadership
campaign are his values you know what
drives him in politics and none of that
has changed on any given day I don't
know he set out his values and his and
his mission in politics you know what he
wants to achieve and none of that has
changed you know what has changed is the
world around us and we now face a
situation where the tax burden in this
country is its highest in 70 years what
we want to do if we get into government
is make the tax system fairer and so you
talk about you know what changes we
might make for the tax system let's look
at the non-dom tax status you know the
the thing which Rishi sunac referred to
as that non-dom thing in prime
minister's questions last week you know
we would abolish non-dom tax status
saving 3.2 billion pounds a year and we
would spend that money in part on an NHS
Workforce plan yeah
so you're very comfortable on that
because obviously that's your brief but
as far as let me just take you back to
tuition fees because you know you did
say that you would scrap them
9250 pounds a year is the annual fee at
the moment there are a lot of students
were thinking I like the cut of their
jib I'm going to vote for them because
then I want to have to pay these tuition
fees and now you're saying sorry guys
but I think you're still talking about
an election a Manifesto for a previous
election
the new election you have a new
Manifesto you know that's the point you
know we lost the last election
so that's the 2019 elections you can't
be trusted and you you turn as much as
you turn things you know I I think
people would expect our party if we
having lost the last general election
um you know by substantial margin to say
look that Manifesto that approach what
we did in 2019 was not what the British
people want and going into the next
election presumably next year we need to
set out our Manifesto for the Times
under Kia stalma what we would do if we
won the general election next year I
wonder how quickly you'll change your
mind on that one well look what we're
being really careful to do is make sure
that anything we put into the manifesto
ahead of the next general election is
fully costed fully funded practical
we're talking about the election which
will be coming up next year we're under
Keith Thomas leadership and we have you
know I know from the shadow treasury
point of view that we are really
ruthless about making sure anything we
promise is fully costed fully funded but
it's a long-term solution rather than a
sticking plaster and those will be our
driving principles going into the next
Manifesto robust responses as always
thanks very much thank you good to see
you